One of the most common questions we get about Android performance
Are about using the Enums prepackage styles in your code.
I mean, this question literally appears everywhere
On the StackOverflow website, on our site for a question and answer after our conversations
Even during a lunch break at a local food session.
Anyway, my name is Colt McCannless.
Patterns in your Android applications are complex and not very complex
That is why there is some confusion
But to go back a bit
If returning to 2009 there was a web page on developers.android.com
She said that the use of anemia should be avoided for reasons of performance.
But then disappeared mysteriously for a while without much clarification
And then of course, it is returned later but in a much smaller condition.
What is the story here?
Well, the truth is a bit different and entirely related
The difference between performance and memory fullness.
See, when your app is loaded,
Android will allocate a portion of the system memory to your application
And for your application to work
DEX code is fully loaded within the subdomain.
But of course, in the end they are shared with the rest of the heap
For any run-time customizations your app will make.
Luckily though, this does not deal with your runtime allocations
However, it puts more stress on the memory system
This of course, when a memory shortage occurs, can cause your application to finish freeing up space.
So with that in mind let's take a look at the effect of prepackage patterns on your application.
Let's say we have here a small base application whose full DEX footprint is 2556 bytes.
Now, we add some integers representing cases that can be used and returned to our system.
After re-translation, the final size of the DEX was 2680 bytes,
This means that these integers are in terms of code size
You have added an additional 124 bytes to our database.
Now for comparison, let's take the same application rule
But its implementation of pluralistic patterns rather than integers
The result here is that the DEX file size is 4188 bytes.
If you add one element of a pattern to this code
Added an additional 1632 bytes for the final DEX file size
Or for those who are proficient in mathematics
Memory is about 13 times greater than the version using int
This, of course, increases your DEX file, which in turn consumes the space of your cluster.
If this is not bad enough,
Although there are also expenses in memory at the time of implementation, attention should be paid to them.
In general, each definition of a pluralistic value costs you about 20 additional bytes.
Of course, in addition to having the object matrix needed to trace the value of the pattern,
So these are 12 additional bytes for the banner as well.
Well, by the way it's 16 bytes in Dalvik.
However, taking this overload occurs at each definition of a code element in your code
This means that the greater the number of prepayments in your app
The larger the memory consumed.
And all of this can get out of control more easily than you think.
For example, if you have used large-scale prepackage patterns,
Or if they are within a library that has been used by many applications on the device,
Each of these small burdens accumulates rapidly to reach a large amount.
And the worst part
Is that you do not really know that the repetitive patterns cause a problem until you hit the code base.
At this point, trying to reform it is indeed a terrible process.
Think of it as such - repetitive patterns are a pattern like Grimlines is not it?
I mean, one or two on their own is not a big problem
I mean, you can get rid of them like something wrapped up or a baseball bat
Or flamethrower if you have any of that next to you, right?
But when there is a whole bunch of them together
Here a problem occurs, and you really want to have a flame launcher.
That's why the basic platform team and people who write the Android code,
They have a strong recommendation
Avoid using prepackage patterns in any part of the code they write.
This allows them to be predictive of potential problems here,
Rather than being interactive
So with that in mind, here are two tips
You should take them into account to address this problem.
First, if you use int for values ​​instead of prep patterns
You can add an IntDef @ note to them,
Which will provide your code with security at build time when LINT errors are enabled,
While the performance and size benefits resulting from the use of int type variables are retained
Basically, this allows you to get the best of both worlds.
Second, if your code is typed correctly
Proguard can in many cases
To improve the conversion of preprogramming styles to int values ​​for you,
So you do not need to think about it or do anything.
Which is one of the few places where free performance gains may be reaped
Note Most of the time, you really have to fight for it.
That's why you need to check out the rest of Android's performance patterns.
And stop asking some questions on our Google+ forum too,
Because you are not alone
So keep calm and write ...
My God! My God!